passé à ce qui s'est passé avec deux
gros témoignages deux gros témoignages
sur des crises et des scandales en
milieu hospitalier euh vous avez été au
courant de de celui de Damien et on va
parler ai aussi de celui de Christina
ils ont été chacun à leur échelle
témoins des failles du système de santé
français Damien a vu un jeune homme de
25 ans mourir sous ses yeux après des
heures d'attente aux urgences c'était la
semaine dernière Christina elle vit la
peur au ventre depuis que sa fille
atteinte de trisomie s'est faite
agresser sexuellement au sein de
l'hôpital dans lequel elle réside on va
démarrer avec le témoignage de Damien et
ensuite Christina d'ailleurs sera avec
nous témoignage de Damien témoin de la
mort du jeune Lucas pour ceux qui n'ont
pas suivi l'affaire regardez ça fait
déjà plus de 2 heur que Lucas 25 ans se
tort de douleur seul sur un brancard
dans un couloir des urg de l'hôpital
d'IER je sais plus quoi faire j'ai
tellement mal et je me sens tellement
faible la cache thoracique est tellement
douloureuse ils ne savent pas quand il y
aura un médecin de dispo je sais plus
quoi faire ses parents n'ont pas la
permission d'entrer pour le voir Lucas
est en fait victime d'une inffection
grave à meningoco au bout de 8h dans le
couloir et un malaise il est enfin pris
en charge trop tard étant donné qu'ils
ont laissé le temps filé comme ça
pendant des heures ils ont condamné
Lucas à mort c'est certain la famille a
porté plainte pour homicide involontaire
contre l'hôpital dans les alors ça
c'était donc la semaine dernière je
voudrais vous remercier d'être avec nous
Damien témoin de la mort de Lucas merci
Damien merci d'être avec nous vous allez
nous raconter tout ça vous allez voir
c'est complètement fou et je vis
remercier Christina d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup Christina vous vous êtes
la maman d'une une jeune femme atteinte
de trisomi 21 qui ne parle plus depuis
un an et qui souffre de troubl
neurocognitifs de type Alzheimer depuis
plusieurs mois elle vit la boule au
ventre votre fils s'est fait agresser
sexuellement au sein de l'hôpital dans
lequel elle réside regardez la victime
est une femme de 50 ans trisomique
malade d'Alzheimer et qui a perdu
l'usage de la parole fin juillet elle
est agressée sexuellement dans sa
chambre par un autre patient surpris en
flagrant délit par une aide soignante
mais au final la direction N jamais
saisi la justice le médecin du patient
misise en cause affirme qu'il y a déjà
eu des soupçons sur ce malade atteint de
troubles psychiatriques Damien
excusez-moi c'est vous Damien Damien qui
était aux urgences et vous vous êtes
donc l'avocat de de de Christina maître
Alexandre lobri merci Christina d'être
avec nous Christina vous êtes la maman
d'Alina une femme atteinte de
trisomie à l'hôpital qui a été violé
l'hôpital elle parle plus depuis un an
elle souffre de troubles neurocognitif
de type Alzheimer en juillet dernier
s'est fait agresser sexuellement vous
allez nous raconter tout ça et on a
maître Alexandre lobri donc avocat de de
Christina qui va nous dire où ça en est
parce que c'est quand même incroyable
écoutz ce deuxième témoignage de
Christina merci en tout cas d'être avec
nous euh vous avez porté plainte pour
viol sur personnes vulnérables ainsi que
pour non assenance à personnes en danger
on va dire où ça en est aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour votre
fille c'était le 27 juillet dernier oui
euh donc le 27 juillet
j'étais encore un cure thermal où
j'amène mon mari qui est beaucoup plus
âgé et très très malade et le 28 juillet
éta encore on est rentré le 29
euh j'ai reçu un appel du médecin
traitant qui me dit euh
elle a vu donc votre fille sur son lit
dénudé la couche enlevée complètement
alors une soignante a retrouvé donc un
homme le P on baissé dans le lit de de
de votre fille à qui on à qui on avait
enlevé sa couche euh et donc euh il
avait enlevé complètement le pantalon et
donc il était euh euh allongé sur elle
les têtes visages contre visage
elle a eu peur elle s'est mis à crier et
euh euh elle est repartie en courant
euh
annoncer répérer ça au médecin la
personne
euh était debout à côté de lit toujours
nu euh elle a fait prendre ses affaires
rentrer dans sa chambre qui est a trois
chambres plus loin de la chambre de ma
fille sur le même couloir alors pour
maîre Alexandre lobri donc l'agresseur
présumé n'a pas été entendu par la
justice il est interné en psychiatrie
depuis de nombreuses années il serait
pas audible en raison de son état
psychique d'après le parquet il est
toutefois soupçonné avoir commis deux
autres faits de l'ordre de l'agression
sexuelle alors en en qualité d'avocat de
la victime de la famille ce que je peux
vous dire c'est nous sommes confrontés à
une affaire dramatique et révoltante
dramatique je le rappelle il y a une
agression sexuelle à l'encontre d'une
personne vulnérable au sein d'un hôpital
généralement dans un hôpital on y va
pour être soigné pas pour être agressé
et révoltante au regard du
positionnement de la PHP qui interroge
pourquoi puisque le 27 juillet il y a
une agression sexuelle
la PHP informe la merde de ma cliente le
2 août le 23 août 2023 il y a une
réunion entre la direction hospitalière
et la mère de ma cliente où on explique
durant cette réunion
que il est vrai les faits peuvent être
constitués d'agression sexuelle on
explique que cette personne ce suspect a
des antécédents
euh d'agression sexuel et de viol mais
on nous explique également qu'il a toute
sa tête oui qu'il a toute sa tête et
entre-temps aucun signalement n'a été
fait auprès de la RS auprès du
procureur il a fallu que nous portions
plainte le 24 octobre 2023 puis le 5
décembre 2023 pour viol et non
assistance à personne en danger et la
PHP aujourd'hui son positionnement c'est
que ils n'ont pas fait ce signalement
puisquil y a une
plainte en l'occurrence la plainte elle
a eu lieu plus de 4 mois après alors il
y a aucune obligation de de séparer
Christina de cet individu où il y en a
mais il y a une obligation au regard du
délit de non assistance à personnees en
danger aujourd'hui la PHP a connaissance
des faits et aujourd'hui la mère de ma
cliente est amenée à recroiser le
suspect à recroiser l'agresseur est-ce
la PHP le dit
clairement elle l'a dit que elle a
proposé soi-disant un transfert ce qui
est faux al on demande à la victime
d'être éloigné et non à l'agresseur
c'est une aberration une aberration une
fois de plus encore une aberration
est-ce que je peux me permettre
excusez-moi
depuis le 2 août tous les jours en
venant chez ma fille à chaque fois soit
à l'allée soit au retour soit quand je
la sortais sur sa chaise roulante je le
croisais à un moment donné chaque jour
j'ai même eu des journées je l'ai dit
aux avocats je l'ai dit à tout le monde
j'ai eu des journées où euh j'arrivais
aux portes à la grille de l'hôpital où
il faut sonner pour qu'on t'ouvre et
déjà à travers euh je le voyais assis
dans la cour un t de lire ou de rigoler
avec ses amis
et je me suis voulu après de ma
faiblesse mais je suis rentrée à la
maison j'ai pas eu la force de continuer
de rentrer et de continuer plusieurs
jours ça m'est arrivé dans ce mois-ci
euh la dernière fois Cyrille je l'ai je
l'ai vu et
comble c'était le 24 janvier donc
c'était mercredi dernier euh je suis
allé chercher ma fille pour l'amener
dans un centre bref d'accueil de jour
et avec les portes de l'ascenseur
s'ouvre et là je donne face à face avec
ce monsieur très chic parce que c'est un
narcissiste il est toujours un costume à
l'hôpital pendant toute ce temps des
années ça fait plus de 2 ans que je le
connais ces costumes il manque la
cravate
costume complet chaussur normale jamais
du tennis le 24 il était un par déessu
beige avec le journal sur le bras et la
poubelle une poubelle dans la main
droite qu'il est allé poser dans le bac
c'est une personne autonome qui a son
toute sa tête qui parle très bien qui
part en vacances avec sa
femme bien sûr euh qui a une vie
autonome euh il n'a pas besoin des soins
sur les feuilles euh que ils ont à
l'hôpital toutes les matins par où c'est
marqué quelle infirmier fait quelle
chambre le réveil son non il est rayé
j'ai demandé pourquoi on m'a dit mais
parce qu'il n'a pas besoin il n'a pas
besoin être aidé à manger il porte pas
des couches bien entendu euh il n'est
pas un chaise roulante bien entendu et
il est libre de toutes ses gestes et des
mouvements et quand il est sorti il
s'est permis nous jetter un
euh bonjour messieurs
dames merci euh voilà merci Christina
juste maître lobri qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de de la justice alors ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est que la PHP
n'a pas pris les mesures nécessaires
aujourd'hui l'agresseur il est euh
voisin de chambre de la victime et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on attend de la
justice c'est qu'elle accélère puisque
ce suspect l'a jamais été auditionné euh
on attend des expertises médicales de la
part du parquet et aujourd'hui l'enquête
traîne il aurait fallu l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire pour aller plus
vite pour qu'un juge d'instruction soit
saisi et qu' puisse avoir les moyens
nécessaires l'enquête traîne et la PHP
n'a elle est pas transparente on ne sait
pas si elle a fait les analyses
gynécologiques euh aucune information
aucune transparence euh aujourd'hui euh
ma cliente elle est livrée à elle-même
et je le dis euh ce suspect ça se trouve
qu'il a récidivé c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe on espère que le fait
que vous soyez venu ici va faire boucher
les choses nous espérons merci
excuse-moi je peux juste ajouter une
chose oui autre le fait que
euh la police est rien n'a été signalé
le jour même de
l'agression toutes les effets de ma
fille la couche euh les draps tout
preuve qui aurait pu être constaté de
viols toutes ont été jeté et l'avait
immédiatement
incroyable voilà merci